we're not just building a car and and
that's it we're we're building a
supercar brand we have delivered two
cars and we have five cars in order it's
typically a person that owns a number of
cars already our clients are typically
living in the Middle East join Russia
and China
it's a really tough game to go into and
rise a lot of money in the beginning but
I would say that our way to enter the
market is like doing doing something
that like we think it should be a lot of
projects similar to symbols are often
based very much on engineering and and
an engineer that has a dream to build a
fast fast light car but they often
forget about the commercial aspects
we're not in a situation where we need
sort of to to get a certain balance of
the the money going in and going out so
so we're we're in it for the long run
our main investors in it for the long
run it's not like you know if we make a
million euro on selling a card and then
we can spend we can spend them again on
on marketing or something like that so
that's that's very comfortable for us